[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai la question posée un album qui
sort ce soir à minuit ou mais juste moi
je reviens sur anissa jeu hors de ma vue
donc ça veut dire que tu as un petit
copain qui l'a trompée
donc tu as ce qu'on appelle casse est ce
qu'aujourd'hui
est ce que je suis en couple non non non
des seuls ouais eh bien écoutez watchmen
est célibataire tous ceux qui nous
regardent enfin les voilà dans la limite
de la jeunesse les personnes perry mi
mai at est célibataire mais c'est vrai
que quand on écoute ses chansons voulait
bazarder tous les hommes à présent et
futur donc bien sûr un match que j'ai pu
lire la welsh dan lay ça va être très
dur et va être très dur à séduire je le
sentais le pif pour ça bah ouais je
donne et jean marc généreux merci
d'avoir acte avec moins de shérif mettre
des bombes